Jim Nantz kind enough to call in as the
Masters is getting underway in Augusta
Georgia right here in the Rich Eisen
show how are you Jim
hello my friend coming he's from right
inside Butler cabin where I'm safely
ensconced I can concentrate on watching
some of the early action before we go up
with some of our broadcast coverage
today and I just wanted to give you a
jingle and thanks and tell you hello I'm
right back at you Jim I guess before we
get into the masters I do want to hit on
what happened a few days ago with
Villanova and where you think that
performance ranks with those that you've
seen in the national championship game
Jim well it was a great team that was
bound together with a lot of different
parts that worked and the more I saw him
the more I began to realize that it was
a special team was just a championship
team they could have competed and and
beaten a lot of near-term recent
national champions I believe I don't
know how far back you go but someone
asked me just right here to gust on the
ground yesterday with well you know how
would they rank as far as great teams in
the last ten years and you know III
think they're right up there near the
top of the list I really believe they
could have beaten just about anybody as
won the championship over the last ten
years and you think Jay Wright punched a
Hall of Fame ticket that night no
question no there's no question that's
done there's no question he will be in
an a spent Memorial Basketball Hall of
Fame what he's really done though is
he's established himself as now the next
wave of coaches kind of become the next
guys who were the leader of their sport
and I'm not phasing out anybody but you
start thinking about guys that are on
the level of Roy Williams course Mike
Mike sous-chefs key Jim Boeheim
that they are you know that they are all
about 20 a little more really more than
20 years older than then than Jay so
he's the next kind of generation you
know we've gone through and Calhoun's
been retired Pitino is out of the game
now we know all about that but but James
got to Championships before the age of
50 and I really truly believe but
they're now a palooka law if they
weren't already and/or gonna be more
big things coming for him and that in
that program do you give your tie out to
anybody no I stopped doing that
unfortunately it was something that I I
really enjoyed doing it to some special
kids that I'd meet along the way and was
never intended to be ever discussed
publicly but it it kind of the cat got
out of the bag two years ago in Houston
and the reaction to it was just so
harshly negative and took away the
purity of the moment I've done it for I
think 11 or 12 years and no one ever
knew about it but then once you know
once a Ryan Archie doc I know was the
recipient and he was kind and sweet
enough to wear it to the press
conference he was so proud of it that
you know people started interpret what
they thought it meant and put their own
snarky narration behind it
hijacked the narrative on what I thought
was a really you know uh I it was meant
to be just a sign of respect and I met a
lot of great kids through the years that
way but if I ever do it again or if I
have done it again no one's ever gonna
know about it because it was never
supposed to be discussed attention
interesting I saw Ryan walking off the
victory platform on Monday night after
we presented the trophy and everything
and and I hadn't seen him since that
night in Houston and I and I had a great
visit with him and he's just I just said
you know I was two years later but I
just wanted you to know that you know
there were players along the way that
make a real impression on you about just
being high quality individuals and
leaders and I said I just you know I'm
excited to see now your your career
starting over to really blossom and
developing and I just have such a great
respect and admiration for you and as I
as I do for all the ones that I shared
that a quiet moment with in the past
I'm you know the lists of Peyton Sivas
and Corey Brewers and and Quinn cooks
and just just great great people who
along the way you know really again made
an impression about the the idea that
they were going to be able to lead a
team to a championship and do things the
right way you know in the classroom in
the locker room on the floor that still
holds true I mean there was just Jalen
Brunson and
this team and hey look the Michigan team
I mean great great young men and I feel
so fortunate to be able to see you know
right right at a front-row seat the the
quality of of kids that are out there in
college basketball I know the game
certainly has gone through a battering
and the others FBI probe and all that's
still ongoing in this commission that's
going to hopefully change the landscape
but you know that's not all negative
when you get the front row seat that I
have to meet some people that's doing
things the right way a great great many
of a majority of well I mean that front
row seat no vogner gave you a quite a
lot see from that I thought he's gonna
be able to put on the brakes next thing
you know he's leaping over the monitor
and he stepped right between where I was
sitting in grant and when he stepped on
our table our table honestly pretty
flimsy is like cardboard table or a card
table
that's what there's a card table what
could have gone right through I mean it
could have been hazardous for him you
know I got out of the way somebody so
you should have taken a charge Hey I
suddenly saw I saw the my Master's week
and the Monday night champey shift games
suddenly were at risk and mean I I
started running for the for cover
come on now Duke guys are supposed to
take the charge Coach K teaches that was
the thing I mean you know grant so let's
talk in a few minutes I have left with
you here Jim yeah the the the awarding
of a garment a piece of clothing that
you definitely will be a part of this
that's coming back in in the cabin from
which you are calling right now who do
you think has the best shot at this
Jim going in well going in I really
thought this year it's going to be one
of these show ponies I really believe it
but you know like a Justin Thomas Jordan
speith Rory McIlroy everybody's playing
coming in
to it as the second story the Tigers
return to Augusta which has a tremendous
excitement and rightfully so he's he's
about to stand over about a four footer
for par at the 7th hole he's one over
right now for the round and what's
interesting is one of the guys in his
group that Marc Leishman is is it
3-under and leading the tournament
through seven holes but it's it's been a
banner year for the sport Tigers return
is almost like it's not only affected
his game with positivity but it's also
given other guys a chance to raise their
their stature and they're all playing
well Phil Mickelson winning recently I
mentioned Corey Justin Thomas won
regionally Jason Day it's just it's just
been a wonderful lead-up to the Masters
I've never seen so many great players
who were in such good form coming here
by the way Tiger made his par at 7 so we
head to the eighth tee at plus one which
is currently tied for 20th hold on a
second Jim like play it play the music
for Jim if he's going to do this sorry
Jim what's going on I hate gorgeous
spring afternoon at Augusta Georgia the
sun is shining the temperatures are cool
and the greatest players in the world
have begun the journey the quest for the
green jacket to make it to Butler cup
cabin come Sunday around 7 o'clock and
this is going to be perhaps the most
springtime conditioning of the week
we're gonna have some weather later in
the way oh I hear the melody still
playing I'm trying to give them aside no
no I heard you I heard you finished in
2nd with that two years ago on Dan show
I heard Jim yeah I've never won my own
sound-alike last one for you before I
let you go is what do you think of this
seemingly bromance that's bloomed
between Phil and Tiger Jim it's real
it's real it's not just hey let's
randomly play around Dolph on Tuesday
together I think a real friendship has
developed there
yeah the respect has always been I know
both of them and I've known Phil to be
dishonest you know I don't feel better
than I'm a tiger
because the tiger and a lot of his glory
years didn't let that many people into
his universe and that's what worked for
him
but I do know them both and I do believe
that they've gotten into their 40s of
course Phil's 47 Tigers 42 and you get
to a certain point where the world looks
a little bit differently than it did in
the past he start to appreciate certain
things and some of the things that maybe
you wouldn't do in the past or maybe
father do in the past I don't think
there's anything father said in the past
but I think you know you you would you
mature become a fuller individual and
these guys realize that they're going to
always be linked you know Jack and Arnie
hue were fierce rivals but look they've
and so Arnie passed away a year two
years this coming September I mean they
were riding off into the sunset together
and they did all kinds of appearances
and they there was a wonderful bond and
friendship there and you know I think
that tiger and Phil as they'd gotten a
little older I think I think they
realized their relationship needs to be
and they want it to be in a different
place they're gonna always the names are
going to come up together and I love
seeing it and whereas I loved seeing
them not only play a practice run it's
used it but maybe the final round
together on Sunday would that be
something it would be Jim and I can't
wait to be settled into my couch with
the rest of America listen to you and
everybody else on CBS with the tradition
unlike any other appreciate the call
well thank you thank you Adam for giving
me the little undercurrent there to be
able to get a rehearsal and there you go
I start to hear the melody and I mean I
I my sense I go in sensory overload and
everything becomes heightened and I get
a good extra fired up so you get Nancy
it sounds like you get Nancy Jim I'm
gonna be honest I'll say answer your
name what is your name oh yes yes you're
getting Nancy you are gay okay can I
give you one I know you're probably up
against America for it we're on the 80
do you need the music that the music
here at okay here we go we're gonna be
we're gonna go live to the a poll
five hundred and seventy yards uphill
for my Tiger standing behind the ball
now stepping into it would driver now he
opened up the day with driver on one and
he's so often done in the past he hooked
it into the trees till 11 made par now
here's a tee shot on the way this one's
one he wants to catch bully and he has
he has blasted it into the fairway in
striking position to go for this par 5
into currently at 1 over par full
first-round coverage coming up later
today have a great one Jim drop the mic
Jim Nantz the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience